[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
they weren't to my point as we weren't
allowed to tell our story because they
didn't want we've never been us last
time until now no matter how hard I
tried no matter how good I was they were
still going to find a way to destroy me
being part of this family it is my duty
to uncover this exploitation and bribery
that happens within our media I'm
generally concerned for the safety of my
family I just really want to get to the
other side of all of this
we just really want to get to the other
side of our list before we're destroyed
because everybody's so horrible to us oh
shut up get your sick buckets ready
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored it's
the nauseating self-serving snows Fest
the whole world is Raging about
[Music]
here's Morgan uncensored good evening
Fernando welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored tonight we'll devote the
whole show to the impact of Harriet
Megan's attack on the monarchy on the
royal family on Brit we're all a bunch
of callous racists who've wrecked their
lives which is why they're now living in
a mansion in California earning
gazillions of dollars to continue
trashing Britain the royal family and
the monarchy I'll talk exclusively to
Megan's half brother Thomas whose own
family were trashed comprehensively
Again by Megan in the Netflix
documentary and there'll be live
reaction from viewers across the UK but
first is my uncensored take and a
warning tonight's show contains spoilers
well Harry and Megan's Netflix series
released to the world this morning is
packed with well not really Revelations
are they sort of rehashed old
Revelations with a new twist as it turns
out we've apparently been wrong all
along Britain is a nasty racist hell
hole where only magnificent Megan stood
up to all this and the world's biggest
victims are not the people of Ukraine or
the people battling covid or people
struggling in a devastating cost of
living crisis no the world's biggest
victims right now are the Duke and
Duchess of Netflix and don't take my
word for it
This Promise of once you're married
don't worry look at better
once they get used to you it'll get
better
of course it'll get better
but truth be told no matter how hard I
try no matter how good I was
no matter what I did
they were still going to find a way
to destroy me
yeah nobody set out to destroy you you
destroyed yourselves in this country
with your ludicrous hypocritical
Behavior the truth be told what she just
did is completely out of garbage Harry
and Megan's romance engagement and
marriage were all greeted with ecstatic
Joy by the British media the public and
the royal family that they've all now
abandoned that's the truth not Harry and
Megan's truth but the actual truth the
first three hours of this Netflix series
painted very different far uglier
picture of this country and our royal
family
eight days after the relationship became
public I put out a statement calling out
the racist undertones of Articles and
headlines that were written by the
British press I wasn't thinking about
how race played a part in any of this I
genuinely didn't think about it some of
the members of the family was like right
but my wife had to go through that so
why should your girlfriend be treated
any differently why should you get
special treatment why should she be
protected and I said the difference here
is the race element I sometimes call the
Commonwealth Empire 2.0 because that is
what it is there is a huge level of
unconscious bias the thing with
unconscious bias is it's actually no
one's fault but once it's been pointed
out or identified within yourself
you then need to make it right
yep we're all racist apparently
sounds like a different country but
let's be clear Britain's one of the most
tolerant and Multicultural nations in
the world we celebrated the Glamorous
modern Flair of neon Royals we eulogize
the newly biracial monarchies the fresh
face of 21st century Britain I wrote
newspaper columns about it myself
including on the day of the wedding the
press and public only turned on Harry
and Megan when their behavior became
obnoxious self-serving and rankedly
hypocritical sadly millions of people
around the world will watch this series
and they'll believe it they'll believe
the smears about Britain and our
monarchy that we're a bunch of bigoted
and hateful people they even blamed
brexit for the racism which apparently
was aimed at Meghan Markle which is just
completely absurd but by far the most
sickening part of this show for me was
the constant use of Harry's late mother
Princess Diana The Stoke sympathy for
Megan
so much of what Megan is and how she is
so similar to my mom
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her
I accept that there will be people
around the world who fundamentally
disagree with what I've done and how
I've done it
but I knew that I had to do everything I
could to protect my family my grandma
nothing says protecting your family like
putting a kids in a reality TV series
does it
having known both women Princess Donna
and Meghan Markle can say with absolute
certainty they're nothing in common
whatsoever I couldn't think of two women
more different when it comes to
compassion and empathy where's Megan's
been for her own father she completely
disowned him as she did all her wedding
actually before the wedding
as the series makes clear
he just suffered a stroke a few months
ago
Miss compassion hasn't even bothered to
call her father to ask how he is and the
answer is we'll find out tonight from
his son Thomas is he's not well at all
Harry's never even met the man whose
daughter he married doesn't care Mr
empathy Mr compassion
yet this man Thomas Markle raised Megan
on his own for many years that wasn't in
the documentary that was glossed over
that was ignored
just like he is now he lives 70 miles
away from them it's about an hour long
cab ride never seen his Grand
grandchildren this show is packed with a
kind of spurious
claims and hypocrisy to become the
Sussex signature we learned they began
making videos about the heroic Journey
six months before their Netflix deal was
even announced and right at the start of
a pandemic it was killing thousands of
people every day they're only concern
was their own situation how mean
everyone was being to them not thousands
of people dying in the streets
clearlius is all planned from the start
the show opens with the claim the royal
family declined to come and in fact they
say no one bothered to ask them because
their biggest complaints are as always
about the terrible media
rarely do we have a holiday without
someone with a camera you know jumping
out of a bush or something within the
family within the system the advice
that's always given is don't react there
was always public pressure with its fair
share of
drama
stress
and also tears and witnessing those
tears there's a lot of people who think
they've got such a problem with with
Paparazzi
see first in this area we're going from
one garage to another like
Paparazzi still harass people
it's amazing what people will do when
offered a huge amount of money
to hand over photographs to create a
story right
so we had to flee the country for family
privacy says Harry as we watch a hundred
million dollar documentary when she
flaunts his young children and shares
private text messages intimate
photographs for the entire world to see
when it comes to Paparazzi I have more
Paparazzi outside my house when I was
forced to leave my old job a
disbelieving princess Pinocchio's lies
then I saw actually outside their houses
at any stage of this documentary
maybe they're mob scenes are to come we
haven't seen any so far that all their
claims of Paparazzi intrusion in the two
trailers turned out to be nothing to do
with them they weren't even at many of
the events which were depicted
so forgive me if I don't think this is
all a load of BS
but frankly the biggest problem with
this series so far is that like the
Sussex themselves is actually it's dull
it's predictable it's cliche ridden it's
simperingly sycophantic it's one long
rendition of all their greatest whinges
and a lot of self-congratulatory
nonsense Harry and Megan sold their
Royal souls to become reality TV stars
but they've got the Charisma to carry
their own sob story they're now grasping
ex-royal version of the Kardashians only
with less class less loyalty and less
brains
well in a moment I'll speak to Megan's
half-brother Thomas Jr exclusively
here's a short reminder of what Megan
Harry said about her father in the show
including a series of supposedly private
messages she sent to him when it emerged
he was too ill to attend their wedding
perhaps and journalist immediately
following him all day every day the
unraveling happened that week when he
wouldn't pick up my call
and instead you're talking to TMZ he had
a heart attack six days ago which is
crazy calling calling calling calling
this is not him saying oh I don't want
to be there no no I get it and the world
is watching this drama player of course
it's incredibly sad what happened she
had a father before this and now she
doesn't have a father
well joining me now is Megan's half
brother Thomas Margaret Thomas thank you
for joining me um first of all uh how is
your father Thomas senior
oh hey guys it's good to be here
um dad is doing very well uh making a
lot of progress he's in good spirits
um sometimes he doesn't feel that
comfortable to actually make a live
appearance but uh he's doing very well
you're there caring for him he had a
massive stroke and I think at one stage
for quite a while he lost the power of
his speech has that returned now is he
able to communicate with you
yeah his uh his speeches is definitely
coming back we're making a lot of
progress with the speech therapy and and
you know if for the most part it's it's
pretty normal it just it goes off after
a few moments but comes back so it's
he's doing very well I'm I'm just very
happy that I could be here every day for
him since since this happened in May or
or what about six months ago were you
both watching the the first half of this
series today
uh let's see I think I think he was he
wasn't able to join us though I mean he
really wanted to be here
um I was watching it and you know I'm
just glad I had my studio magic tear pen
with me so I could have a tear come out
of my left eye while I was watching it I
mean that moment when Prince Harry has
never met your father
says that Megan has no father
what did you think of that
I think it's horrible
um the documentary is so far off on so
many different levels so many it's just
it really is really a little bit
disturbing
um
saying that you know she doesn't have a
family and she doesn't have a father and
then Harry's saying that you know she
has no father now that's just ridiculous
yeah I mean it's incredibly hurtful I
also have always had sympathy with your
father because I felt that he was thrown
to the wolves with no experience of
dealing with this kind of media
intensive media attention he tried to do
the right thing he came unstuck and they
just disowned him
um has she made any attempt to contact
your father since he had his stroke
none whatsoever and you know I totally
agree with you on on the fact that none
of us were ever coached or given any
help with the paparazzi or press since
the very beginning which has caused a
lot of problems
um
nobody reached out I actually reached
out and and all I got back was distant
family and she doesn't know us which is
just you know it's just very bizarre
how she just basically brushed the
entire family under the carpet like we
don't exist and then lied about not
having a family and lied about you know
she doesn't have a family that she's
always wanted you know we've always been
here it's
documentaries way off I mean that's
that's what's actually prompted me to
work with my own production team
um and coming out in like 2023 we're
gonna have you know our side of the doc
our side of a documentary that's going
to shed a lot of light well I don't
blame you I mean
this is one of my family doing this to
my family I want to do the same thing
and set the record straight it seems to
me that she's decided you're all too big
a problem therefore you have to be cut
loose and I gotta be honest I I knew
Megan for a bit before she met Harry did
exactly the same to me bang you know
done she did that to many people that
she knew that she'd either worked with
or was friends with or whatever it just
seems to me she's what I would call a
ruthless social climber who just when
people are no longer yeah you know no
longer appropriate parts of her Circle
they have to be expunged quickly so she
can move on up the ladder
absolutely and I think a lot of greed
plays into that fact also I mean the
amount of unprecedented files photos
videos and documentation that that we're
going to be including in our documentary
it's going to tell a whole different
story and I think the the I think the
general public and the UK and America
knows
that now the markers aren't bad people
we're we're just like a normal family
like everybody else we do exist and when
when one person tells lies and then
tells 10 other lies to cover the one lie
and it keeps on going you know this is
what happens you'll you you end up
looking ridiculous there's a staggering
moment Thomas where
um Ashley who is I think your niece
who's Samantha's daughter uh befriended
Megan and was gonna go to the wedding
and then Megan is apparently advised by
some funky at the palace that wouldn't
be a good idea because Samantha's not
invited so this happens
how do we explain that this half-sister
isn't invited to the wedding but that
the half-sister's daughter is
and so with Ashley the guidance at the
time was to not have her come to our
wedding
I think I said I was
hurt on some level but I understood
where it was coming from
to know that it was because of my
biological mother that
this relationship that's so important to
me
was impacted in that way
[Music]
I feel like because of her was taken
away
has been hard
yeah actually it was because of Megan
that it was taken away Megan could have
had her there as you wanted to have it
there instead she wanted to have a bunch
of celebrities she barely knew from the
Clooney's to the beckhams to Elton John
to James Gordon to Timbuktu I mean he
looked like anyone she'd met on the
party circuit in the previous two years
got the invite but a lot of Harry
friends weren't there and nor was this
niece who she makes a big thing in the
documentary saying we were so close
yeah well I mean there you have it you
know one lie turns into 20 other lies
she didn't have a family so therefore
nobody was invited
I mean
I mean who doesn't invite their family
to a wedding especially a royal wedding
and it's not like it's not like anybody
in my family asked her for one nickel or
anything ever we were all actually like
happy for her when all this happened but
the slow turn of events showed the true
colors of this woman when you when you
finish watching today these first three
episodes what was the kind of overview
about what's happened to to Megan and
Dean what do you think of Harry
well my general overview is I can't
believe
that she was able to be in this position
all by my father's doing by the way
to be in that position and to know what
you're getting yourself into
and then go in there and try and change
a thousand-year-old tradition and
monarchy to to your own liking
who does that
um
it's it's still it's still a big
question I mean my father and I we talk
about it quite a bit it's like I mean
how could you even even consider doing
that you were
everything every woman in their life
could ever dream of you had and you had
to go and make waves and accusations and
be difficult and overall you know taking
Harry away from his family right yeah
I'm afraid I think he's completely
described like I said
um Thomas I gotta leave it there thank
you very much indeed for joining me
please send your father my best weren't
you because I've been concerned about
him
um I'm glad to hear he's he's on the
mend absolutely obviously been a scary
time for you and the family please send
him my very best
absolutely will do thank you so much for
having me all right good to talk to you
well drew me out of zero on a certain
standard uh Robert Johnson and professor
of black studies at Birmingham
University for Hindi Andrews welcome to
both of you Robert I mean pretty
startling isn't it when you hear her own
half-brother talking that way about this
and how they feel as a family
they're starting It's upsetting I'm sure
for them I mean you know they do seem
when they're on the television to be
fairly normal people right and uh you
know Thomas Markle seniors come in for
an awful lot of criticism for when he
you know allegedly sold out the way he
did but there was no support for him at
the time and I think that he did need
that support how can you call yourself
miscompassion how can Harry say she's so
like Diana who really was full of
compassion and not even contact your
father when he brought you up on his own
for years when he has a massive stroke
well as you said it wasn't even
mentioned that he brought her up on his
own for years in the documentary I
thought the documentary but didn't
really address some of the big issues
that were out there Harry talks about
institutional racism at the at the
palace he doesn't address the facts I
remember I did the story years ago when
he you know he made racist comments
about a a Pakistani he called it a p
word yeah he did and he tape recorded it
and distributed that tape yeah to all
his friends now that actually is not
Harriet himself has actually been the
biggest proven racist is in modern Royal
that is that is a clear case of it yeah
he's accusing everybody else of oh it's
our unconscious but that wasn't
particularly unconscious but perfectly
conscious you know he he recorded it he
did it he mocked the guy and the guy's
father was Furious okay handy Andrews my
problem with all these racism claims
which they keep spewing is this all
generic there are no specifics there's
no meat on the bone there's no names
there's no incidents there's nothing we
can point to which actually says anyone
in the royal family has been racist to
them or anybody else now without that
why should we believe a word they're
saying
well this is what institutional racism
is that the whole point is that you
don't need to have somebody waving a
Nazi flag to be racist it's about the
way she was treated in the Press it's
about the way she was treated by the
family it's about the way she was
restricted in her role it's about her
true color being black and that being
black didn't fit into it what's he gonna
do with her skin
again what does it got to do with her
skin color who are the royal family said
anything racist about or two Meghan
Markle we don't know we've not been told
nobody defense well In fairness they've
tried In fairness they have actually
tried to defend the family because
someone did raise the color of the baby
and they didn't say who that was we
could we could guess it's not defending
the family
they're smearing all of them they've
never said who it was but
no but the point is it's not about one
thing so if you look at her media
president look when she that first story
when she came when it came out they were
dating Straight Out of Compton
headline you know otherwise positive
feature which actually was wrong by nine
yeah she came from an area I know Hindi
I know L.A I know where Compton is I
know where she was brought up it's about
eight nine miles away the story was off
by eight nine miles exactly the feature
wasn't actually remotely derogative
effects about her
no but you look at they have to look at
the the for example you're saying that
she was a diva she was she was he was
mean to people she was no no she wasn't
she was just acting in a way that many
Royals act but she became seen as this
aggressive black woman she's a diva
that's racism
again I never saw anybody use her color
in the British media as a stick to
attack her ever never saw it it never
happened
nor have I seen any evidence in anyone
in the royal family was ever racist to
either of them
so there are a number of people who've
put together comparisons you know how is
Kate treated Kate does one thing and
he's treated this way Megan does one
thing you treat a different ways he has
millions of negative headlines he goes
around saying the n-word anymore and
you're saying
really
well I would say well I mean I think
when you have an institution which is
overwhelmingly white which is only a
story she's in it because she's black in
the first place because she wasn't black
we're gonna be talking about all of this
where he then treats her in a way which
is clearly problematic she then leaves
and says look I experience racism and
thought about committing suicide it was
so bad I think we would have to say yeah
well I want to see the evidence of that
too because she said she said a senior
person at Buckingham Palace told her she
couldn't have help for her Suicidal
Thoughts because it would be bad for the
brand of the palace who was that person
and when did that conversation happen
because like a lot of what Meghan Markle
says none of it is borne out by actual
evidence it's just her saying it playing
the race card damaging the market
damaging the raw family royal family
there is lots of evidence that the Royal
Family's press machine is essentially
like the mafia and you can't just say
what you like but like I think you know
yes I mean this is yes that's not true
Mafia was that's ridiculous you can just
say whatever people who killed people
for fun is that what you're liking the
British royal well the Royal Africa can
I just can I just point out the Royal
African the Royal African company was
the company which Enslaved the most
people that looked like me in the
history of this planet so actually yes
the Royal Family actually does have a
murderous past and it's a racist person
a deeply Colonial person actually is but
if you think they're still murdering in
a superior position they're still
murdering people I think the point how
many people are the royal family
murdered in your lifetime
how many people has the system the Euro
family represent murdered in my lifetime
Millions actually I mean this is the
problem right if you think they're still
doing this benign thing
it probably it is
to say the problem with these
conversations is that again there's no
substance to it other than go back in
history and say that hundreds of years
ago the colonial Britain led by the
royal family behaved in a bad way we
know that and they've been apologizing
throughout the last 60 years for it yeah
but I mean this is also about accuracy
isn't it and we this this documentary I
I can only speak as I find there was one
particular moment where I was on a poor
position in South Africa inside the
Archbishop tutu's compound his house and
they used that photograph of them
walking away holding the baby to say
with a lens in the in the picture to
suggest that that was intrusive by the
paparazzis we're seeing the picture here
now that's the narrative that photograph
was taken with three people standing
there on the poor position I was
standing next to Sarah Latham and we got
our name now Sarah Latham the press
secretary who had arranged the position
with them and that was all official all
agree and then we went from there into
the into the Archbishop Archbishop
teacher's house where they had tea and
showed the baby again the Press couldn't
show pictures of that baby under the
regulations that we now have agreed of
course the death of Diana what upsets me
about this documentary about anything
else is they've used all of these things
Harry says he can't remember a lot about
his childhood with Donna apart from the
fact that there were a lot of yeah he's
utilizing Diana the fame of Dinah in
this documentary it's disgusting and
he's utilizing that to get an old
narrative across and the British media
Has Changed by the way the reason he's
doing it is he's getting 90 million
dollars
he's doing the very thing he's accused
the tabloids of doing when his mother
was alive which is using her her image
and everything about her Panorama for
commercial game right exactly Panorama
Robert delivery there thank you very
much indeed for joining me handy thank
you very much indeed for joining me
coming next Harry and Megan wield
Princess Diana's memories as we just
discussed to defend their actions and
planes but does that comparison have any
credibility at all have guessed it in
four barrel to debate that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so much of what Megan is and how she is
is so similar to my mum
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her
well
joining me now a royal correspondent for
Vanity Fair Cody nickel Princess Diana's
former Butler pool barrel and historian
and orthodontist well Paul you and I
I had lunch with Princess Diana and a
Young Prince William is 13. at
Buckingham Palace uh because of the
palace I'm sorry you were the butler
served a very nice meal I have to say I
had two hours of Dinah and she was
completely Charming compassionate
empathetic and all those things I also
need Meghan Markle who in my estimation
from everything that happened before
during and after when I knew her is a
complete piece of work devoid of any
real compassion witness her father and
the family devoid of empathy uh who's
taken this Prince away from his family
now and is trying to exploit the Royal
titles for maximum gain that is not what
Dinah did no she never was in it it's a
personal game not a penny when you heard
Harry say that is he lost his mind I'm I
I I'm gobsmacked
you cannot compare Princess Diana to
Megan they are two totally different
creatures in totally different spaces at
totally different times and if you had
lived with her for 10 years as I did I
can honestly say there is no comparison
Princess Diana just none Paul I mean
Harry is a man in love he's in love with
Megan and his memory of Diana is one she
was a 10 and 11 year old boy yes is he
in love or is he is Donald Trump told me
have we got the Donald Trump clip oh do
we have to play the Donald Trump Claire
yeah
have we got it this is what Donald Trump
said it wasn't really love he thought
was a problem let's listen to this
here we go it's coming it's the magic of
live television
Harry is whipped do you know the
expression I'm familiar with them I
won't use the full expression and Harry
is whipped like no person I've ever seen
the most weak man in the world this is I
don't know that's going to be a big one
but he is he is a whipped man yeah yeah
the full expression is he's [ __ ]
whipped I don't want to take my advice
on romance and love from two Neanderthal
men over 50. quite frankly I think
you're all missing the point I thought
the main takeaway message which you
could learn from and all three of us
could probably be humiliated by was the
relationship the crony relationship
between the British press and the palace
there's Mutual dependence which was
massively sorry no it's corrupting
as a former tabloid newspaper editor for
10 years yes I know more about that
relationship than you do with it
historically I probably actually than
you do because I was on the shopping the
idea that somehow there was something
delusion collusion between the
newspapers and the journalists
sorry having covered the rules for the
best part of 15 years let me just tell
you and it one of the things that
annoyed me so much in what Harry said
was the idea that we are just a royal
rotor that had just drip fed material
from the house if only it was that easy
it's contempt for the bridge
by the way what about this this is a guy
whining about the media what she's
what's he done since Royal duties he's
now on James corden's bus stop he's
doing Oprah Winfrey he's doing a Netflix
reality show the guy never stays off of
using the media doing it all he wanted
was cash and what we need to be honest
about is the conservative predominantly
conservative press rely on access to the
royal family for their Scoops for their
biographies even eyes historian oh if I
go too far will I get into the Royal
archive the truth is it's compromising
and if we're all done our job properly
maybe there would be a royalty which has
the truth is
the truth is Harry has always attacked
tabloids doing the ones that I used to
edit for exploiting the royal family for
commercial gain now he is exploiting his
hatred of the royal family for
commercial game even using his own
mother the late Princess Diana to do
that for money for hard dollars
and it is disgusting hypocrisy his
mother his mother would be very unhappy
she'd be furious about what was
happening now because it upsets William
it upsets Kate and those boys had a pact
that these interviews would not be shown
again on National Intelligence
let me bring in we've got a stellar
panel of ordinary members of the public
here all of whom have strong opinions we
won't get to all of you and you know
that but I've got a Fran Foley Winston
who's in Dublin Fran what was your take
on what we saw today
but it was just so
cringe-worthy I don't know how much
it was halfway through
an Engaged chest you know I don't think
their days are that long in real life
ridiculous
so you weren't impressed
no and I'm actually I've been a group of
messages right we're having a problem
with your with your link now I'm gonna
try and come back to a bit later let's
go now to uh we're gonna get a Nicola
Myers what is your view you have a
different view I think Nicola
um okay so my view of the Netflix series
as it happens this morning I've actually
watched episode one two and three back
to back
um and I loved it okay I absolutely
loved it before I watched it I wasn't
sure of my opinion of everything that
had gone on with Megan and Harry and if
they were set out to jeopardize their
British Monarchy
um after watching it I am on their side
I'm for Megan and Harry why I absolutely
am why they're madly in it off the
Madeline I'm very happy for them why
trash their family why trash their
families
why trash the families I don't think
they've purposely set out two trash
there legally purposely shut up
Harry has got scared of all the
um racial abuse
um that the love of his life was getting
it saw it happening what had happened to
his mother where his mother got murdered
and and he's he's panicked of God
okay all right let me go to magali gore
who's in uh
oh we haven't got my guardian I'm sorry
we'll come back to it we'll come back to
another one of our panel in a moment I
mean it's interesting isn't it lots of
different reactions I've heard some
people say they like them and they
support them you see that on social
media a lot I gotta say walking around
today I didn't meet anyone in Kensington
on the streets it was anything but
Furious yes I've not had anyone on my
Twitter feed coming in saying they're
saying that at all and people saying
we're going to cancel on Netflix
subscription there seems to be a real
reaction interesting exploitation of
Princess Diana's image it's very
anti-british I'm going to own that and
that really struck me this morning in my
little British home I thought gosh I
felt almost like I was under siege and
I'm fairly neutral in terms of you know
where my affections lie whether it's for
the Royals I was watching with my wife
silly it's her birthday today happy
birthday to my wife um and we couldn't
think of a better way to enjoy her
birthday than to spend three hours
watching those whining little brats in
Montecito but we sat and watched it and
about halfway through we turned it away
this is really boring and the reason it
was boring was because they were
repeating so much of the rehash stuff
which we heard on Oprah it's like it's
the same it's like Elvis playing all his
old hits he's not quite as good that's
not appealing to you the voyeuristic
let's have a look in them on to sit at
home oh they met on Instagram all those
aspects to be fair peers I mean it's
going to the generation below even me
let alone you well let's go let's go all
right we can go to magali gore now is
Gore I'm sorry magali Gora who's in
Cheshire my God I think you can hear me
now what's your view
yes hi hi well to be fair I I I have
double feelings about it but one feeling
that I can say is that as you can see
I'm a woman I'm Brown and when I saw
royalty getting in love and she was a
brown
princess because she became a princess
uh the door went over for so many dreams
of little girls like me when I was young
and I was raised in a very white
Community uh racist racist now sometimes
people are not uh used to how you look
like they're not used to how you
um what your roots are or what your
background is or that you handle things
maybe differently
um I loved the wedding for example the
wedding was this American uh well I
agree with you I wrote all that I wrote
all this uh magali I wrote a big piece
for the okay on Sunday saying exactly
what you've just been saying I think
that was the General mood of this
country that's why I'm so angry that
they're now trying to make out they were
driven out by races Britain races Royals
racist media none of that was true now
what what did you think now having
watched it today what's your view of
them now
um it is a repeat on a lot of things and
I have to be honest to you still we
cannot really feel what she felt I only
know that when you're coming in an
institution that's where she comes in in
a family that is a very strong a very
serious family a very you know look at
the queen she is born to do this you
know so this is what you do this is what
you're gonna live and then it comes a
girl from America that thinks with the
American background to the red carpets
oh I'm gonna make it now look at me no
no no no no you have to live like the
protocols yeah and I think that's a
struggle okay
I've got to leave it there I'm gonna
take a break but thank you for that I'm
gonna come back after the break and
we'll talk more about this particularly
also Meghan Markle mocking the moment
she met the queen who had to curtsy and
Harry's response
does it get any more disrespectful than
that
we'll talk about it after break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there's no class in some person who goes
sit like this cross your legs like this
use this Fork don't do this curtsy then
wear this kind of hat it doesn't happen
and I remember in the car and driving up
and you know how to curtsy right
thank you
and I just thought it was a joke
I mean Americans will understand this we
have Medieval Times dinner and
tournament it was like that like I
curtsied as though I was like
[Music]
pleasure to meet you your majesty
yeah nice right mocking Our Queen
mocking uh the fact she had to show her
respect by just learning how the
courtesy of Prophecy it's not hard to
learn is it if you're marrying into the
family well joining me now is the editor
of Hollywood unlocked basically niece
and Martin Luther King Jr are Vita King
and conservative radio host Ben Ferguson
I still have Paul and Katie with me so
um
let me start with you if I may Ben
Ferguson what does America make of this
I mean surely they're not falling for
this are they
yeah can you please come get your
Kardashians that's number one number two
uh it seems like these two individuals
that are obsessed with being private
people and being out of the public eye
are actually a bunch of narcissists that
are totally obsessed with being in the
public eye it was a crybaby special I
mean I at full disclosure I could only
watch so much of it peers before I said
give me a break roll my eyes and moved
on with my life so I would say if you
want to waste three hours of your life
and you love drama and your soap opera
isn't coming in watch this because it's
amazing but this rewriting of of History
through their eyes like there's some
somehow victims they're not victims
she's crazy and she's trying to destroy
a family here and I and I I used to kind
of feel sorry for Harry I don't anymore
no because he's sitting there doing it
with her like you can even see at the
curtsy moment that you just came in with
here he looks at her almost like she's
crazy and maybe in three or four or five
years she'll realize yeah
I think that's the moment we'll look
back on
I suspect in a couple of years and
that'll be a Tipping Point let's go to
alvida King I want to think Dr King is
one of my all-time Heroes as he is many
people he truly was somebody who stood
up to racial Injustice racial inequality
like nobody in modern times uh and it
cost him his life the idea that these
two are in any way on any level
people doing similar stuff is to be
fanciful they're just sitting there in a
mansion in California spray gunning
their families uh calling them a bunch
of callous vile races without any
evidence aren't they
um do I just jump in well here's
off you go
off you go can you hear me I can hear
you yeah can you hear me okay all right
well here I am I grew up with the
Princess and the Pea Cinderella lately
wakanda forever and exploring all these
various cultures and so there is no
happily ever after in Cinderella land if
you're from two different cultures and
so what we have is a cultural confusion
on Megan's part and she wants to
superimpose her culture on her husband
and their family and that just doesn't
work but I'm remindful of my uncle
Reverend Dr Martin Luther King Jr we
must learn to live together as brothers
and I'll say as sisters or perish
together as fools now there's only one
blood and one human race and so to put
racism into everything doesn't
necessarily ring true either and really
Britain had a queen I think it was
Prince Queen Sophie who was part German
and part black African African person so
it's not like the monarchy is supposed
to skin color but there's only one blood
in One race but I think Megan is mixing
Maybe
Hollywood fantasy and her pain of what
she wants to see but you can't topple a
whole line of traditions based on pain
but past pain there is communication it
takes some guts to even speak out and
say some of these things but we want to
bring this back into a reality and I
think that's the problem Avida that's
one of the most brilliant analysis I've
heard actually of the whole faraga thank
you absolutely brilliant
um I want to bring in Jason Lee now you
you fall through all this you think
they're great Heroes and deserve all the
awards they're getting and the Freedom
Fighters standing up to the impressive
Brits dude
well I'm not obsessed with them to the
point that I'm following every move that
they're making but I have watched the
documentary and so far I I love it and
I'm somebody who's black and white and
you know I've listened to some of the
people on the show today the guy who
started at the top of this segment has
just annoyed me you can tell he probably
doesn't have much love in his life and
the woman before the last segment she
was probably a bit oversized and
unattractive
doesn't really sound like she had hold
on wait we already heard what you had to
say clearly you're mad that there's
black blood in the bloodline for the
royal family but since you want to talk
about if you want to talk about racism
in the UK let's talk about the racism in
UK thing because the blood diamonds at
the Buckingham Palace have not been
returned I said you're very consumed
with the man who's in love with a black
woman that's the problem that you have
but this is the
dealership
here's the deal everybody got to talk
before all right everybody got to talk
before
Jason here's the problem Jason it's when
you get to the specifics of who in the
royal family has actually been racist
there's no answer there's no evidence
there are no facts it's all just smear
by association they're racist they're
blind to it all they're unconsciously
biased blah blah blah where where is the
meat on the bone where are the facts
well we haven't seen it all yet and I
think that we have to let them tell
their story right we're both in the
media one thing I love about you pierce
you say what you feel what you think
regardless of how people feel and I
think they should be given the same
Freedom we enjoy talking about them let
them tell their story so we can talk
about their story I I look at their Love
Story from their point of view and I
look at how it's been reported and I can
enjoy it all without feeling you know
getting in my feelings I think that how
she described meeting the queen I don't
know how I would have felt if I would
have met the queen I didn't have that
privilege but I probably would have been
nervous too and I don't know what
preparation went on I mean what we're
looking at is very public people who are
under scrutiny who had private lives and
now we're seeing what that lives you
know what Jason she met the queen she
married clean privately and she was with
the Queen's grandson who probably does
know how you greet the queen
exactly exactly
that was a great panel I want to thank
Jason
I think you would like to just verify
I get it alvida one second Ben just to
clarify you do have love in your life
yeah yes yes I have a wife that loves me
three children that love me and I said
nothing about it thank you to my panel
thank you very much
verdicts here from Teddy and Paul
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my brother-in-law used to be the person
in charge of training William and
Harriet Sandhurst military academies all
the Royals need to go down there
printing for their passing out bracelet
I thought you'd want to know that I've
seen the royal family in action in
private after the passing outbreaks are
the most loving affectionate relaxed
people just like any other normal family
we watch them all hug each other tease
each other it was lovely to be a part of
I witnessed it at both Harry and
Williams passing outbreaks Megan is
talking absolute bleep thank you
Charlotte my sister
um we're all pretty much the same with
my family uncensored let me go to
samsara quickly in Canterbury very
quickly samsara your view
my view is it's fascinating just like
you said it's a big statement that says
nothing's wrong with me nothing's wrong
with us we're normal people we've had an
experience and the thing that Harry
talks about is unconscious bias so I
know you've mentioned racism and perhaps
it's not being called out just yet
explicitly in the documentary but it's
the blind spots it's the areas where
people might well be well-meaning but in
fact underlying that are some prejudices
and judgments
okay that's a good point uh Katie your
overview really from all the discussions
we've had I mean we haven't mentioned
yet the little digs that were going on
about Kate and William yeah the other
people you know fitting the mold wires
well he said you know the men in the
family married women who fit the mold
well I think you can look at William and
Kate in their 10-year love story before
they even married and say this is one of
the most enduring love stories of
overall history and respectful of the
institution which gives them the
luxurious life they have but apparently
you know the they were called towards
you know the couple and there was that
because when Meghan Markle which was the
first time she's Barefoot must have
hugged them all he's like she's a 36
year old divorcee yes I'll probably give
her a bit of a wide birth cells yeah
Paul remember respect don't trash the
royal family we love them here in
England they're our institution remember
what your mother would say to you your
mother would say to you Harry I'm proud
of you for being a member of our royal
family I'm proud of your brother I
always thought that you'd be his wingman
and she was very proud to be a princess
I've got letters at home I want to
absolutely hate the rift with William
absolutely and the fact that they would
go on national television now for the
second time and trash William and Kate
and Charles and all of it it's just it
would be and I have to say Harry is
monopolize Diana and her Legacy and can
you imagine how that must feel for the
Prince of Wales yes she was both of
their mother and he is and by the way
they just lost the queen right they're
all still grieving the loss of our
greatest motto thank you both very much
come back next week for part two that's
it for me whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign